( intro music )
( applause )
John Grant: Thank you all
for being here tonight.
And listening to us tell you
a little bit about Curiosity.
So, starting out with
why Gale Crater.
Well, here is a map of Mars.
We've landed in six locations
before Curiosity.
Why do you need to go
for a seventh? Haven't we--
haven't we been all
over the planet?
It looks kinda like
a shotgun blast to me here
in terms of the yellow marks.
Well, Mars is a smaller planet
than the Earth.
But without oceans it's got
about the same land area
as the surface of the Earth.
And I travel a fair amount,
more than I'd like to
but if I had only been
to six places
on the surface of the Earth,
I wouldn't know much about it.
Let me give you one example.
There is a place
where I used to live
in Western New York, called
Letchworth State Park.
It's called the
'Grand Canyon of the East'.
A fabulous place.
But if I had
never been out west
and didn't know
about the Grand Canyon,
it would be
kind of a different story
in terms of
where I might choose to go.
But what if the rocks
in the Grand Canyon
weren't of interest
and the ones in
Letchworth State Park,
even though it's smaller,
were.
So what you really need
when you are looking
at landing sites is not only
do you have to know something
about the planet and
where the good places are
but you've got to
bring together the expertise
to be able to look
at those places
and find out which ones
are the most relevant
for the kinds of things
that you want to accomplish
with your mission.
So, we started with about
65 landing site candidates
from our Science Laboratory,
Curiosity.
We whittled it down
to the final four
that you see here in white.
Holden Crater,
Eberswalde Crater,
Mawrth Vallis
and of course Gale Crater
where we ended up going.
And just to give you
a sense of
what we found attractive
about those four places
and I'll point out
that the yellow ellipsis
that you see here
are all 25 kilometers long
by 20 kilometers high.
We've got Mawrth Vallis
on the upper left.
There is this stratigraphy,
these layers of rock
that we see there
that we see a sense of
different kinds of clays
from top to bottom
and it's an ancient,
ancient set of rocks
that tell us something about
the earliest
history of the planet.
A question about Mawrth was
how did those rocks
get to be there
and we never really
could get a handle on that.
Although work has been
moving forward.
Down here in the lower left
we see a place
called Holden Crater.
It's about the same size
as Gale Crater,
about 100 miles across
and here we see along the side
of the crater sediments
that have been washed down
into a big fan.
It's the best alluvial system
preserved on Mars.
Over here on the lower right
we see Eberswalde Delta.
A place where we might go
and sample sediments
that have been
deposited by water
running down through a river
in the ancient past.
The problem or question
about these two on the bottom
were they occur relatively
late in Mars' history
compared to when we think
it was the wettest.
And if we got there
we're seeing a fairly narrow
period in the history of Mars.
So we want to know
relative to habitability
when those things occurred,
we might want to
sample a place with a section
that's preserved
is much older.
And that brings us to Gale
up here in the upper right.
You'll notice that in this
100 mile across crater,
150 kilometers across,
there is this mountain of
material.
Five kilometers or
three miles high.
And the layers
that are in that mountain
are very much like pages
or chapters in a book.
And when we look
at the chemistry
or the chemical composition
of those layers,
we see a transition
from the kinds of things
that were deposited in water
in wet conditions
near the bottom
to drier things
as we move up
through the section.
And so Gale became a chance
to sort of read the chapters
related to the changing
environment on Mars,
from when it was wetter
to when it's relatively
dry today.
And that's why
we picked Gale Crater.
Gale Crater lies across
this transition on Mars.
What you see here,
this topography
where the yellows and
the reds are relatively high
and the blues
and purples are low.
And Gale right there
in the middle
straddles this boundary called
the 'planetary dichotomy'.
And what we see here already
visible is this mound;
this mountain of material,
Mount Sharp.
If we zoom in
on the crater proper,
we are looking across here
towards the south
and on the north side
between the small crater
that you see
in the middle of the mountain
is about where
we were planning to land.
So we wanted to land
and be able to drive directly
over to the flank
of the mountain
transitioning up between these
layers of material,
these chapters in the book,
telling us about
the environmental history
of Mars.
But there was
another target there.
A small channel that runs down
the wall of the crater.
This is a closer view now.
The top of the crater
is now to the north,
so I've turned things
around on you.
This is an image from
the Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter.
There is this incredible
synergy between
the cameras
that we have in orbit
and the pictures that
we can take of the surface,
and the things that
we can do on the surface
to ground truth that data.
This data,
we can resolve things
that are about
20 meters across.
The camera has a resolution
of six meters per pixel.
And we can see
that channel now
coming in from the upper left
and draining out into
a fan of sediment.
We call this an alluvial fan.
And there are many examples
of this on Earth
that we see in places
for example like Death Valley.
So this became
a very important
secondary target,
to the layers
in Mount Sharp,
for our exploration.
Well, here is the view
from the surface
after Curiosity landed.
This is one of
my favorite images
from the mission
because to me it's almost like
you are standing
in Death Valley
looking up the west
at the Panamint Mountains.
And seeing this
fan of material,
you can see the bright outline
of Peace Vallis,
this channel coming down
and the sloping sort of
deposit of sediment
that's being
laid down by that river
some time in the past.
We are way down
at the very far end of that
where we landed
with Curiosity.
In fact we weren't even sure
if we were going to be
on those sediments.
Now here is an overhead view,
this time
from the HiRise camera,
which can image things that
are about three feet across.
It has a resolution of
about 25 centimeters
or about a foot.
You can see
where Curiosity landed,
the two blue spots over here
on the left.
And those are the tracks
of the rover.
When we landed,
because we had
mapped the surface
of our landing ellipse
before we got down
to the surface of the planet
we knew that there were
some different terrains
that we were likely to sample,
depending on where we landed.
And because we landed
at that spot there,
we happen to be very close to
three different kinds
of material
that were sort of like
a Rosetta Stone
we thought for understanding
the geology of our traverse
as we went across to
Mount Sharp.
The most of the material for
the left two-thirds
of the image was one type
and the lower right corner
was another,
and then the brighter
whitish-blue stuff up there
is a third.
Seeing this juncture of these
three different materials
knowing that
they held to clues to
what was going on in Gale
and that they might be related
to that alluvial fan,
drove us literally
in the opposite direction
than we intended once
we got down on the surface.
Mount Sharp is down
to the left--
to the lower left,
your left, my right.
We went east,
we went to your right.
And it paid off.
Very soon
after we got started,
we started to find
these outcrops.
The pebbles that you can see
weathering out,
that are rounded.
Becky Williams
who is here tonight
was the lead author
on a science paper
that first described these
as 'deposits related to
that river
flowing down
that side of the canyon'.
Now,
in Death Valley it doesn't,
it doesn't rain very often.
But when it does,
that water comes out fast.
And I can almost imagine
when I see
these sorts of things,
you know water up to
my thigh kinda thing
draining across the surface
depositing these gravels.
What an amazing
and different place
this must have been
three, three and
a half billion years ago.
We got into this place
called Yellowknife Bay
and here's our dried up
lake sediments.
This is a mudstone.
We drilled down
into this rock.
The rocks weren't red,
they are gray.
They tell us something about
the conditions in the past.
When we look
at the chemistry it tells us
that these clays that are
in here were deposited
in conditions that were
relatively neutral,
that is not too acidic,
not too basic.
But we've already sampled
sediments washed down
in a river
and ancient lake deposits.
And we haven't even
gotten to Mount Sharp yet.
So, clearly the first bit
of information
that we got back
from Curiosity,
really sort of set us
on our ear,
in terms of understanding Mars
as a planet
and how it evolved.
Since leaving Yellowknife Bay
and these ancient lake
deposits
we've been traversing across
a landscape
that's littered
with sedimentary rocks.
You can see some of those here
in the foreground.
And we've been sampling these
as we've gone,
trying to understand more
about the relationship
between sediments
washed down in this river,
Peace Vallis and out
onto this fan of sediments
versus the sediments
that have been
shed off
the side of Mount Sharp.
There's still kind of
an uncertainty
in terms of
where some of these
different sediments
have come from
and what their origin is
in relationship
to the timing of the formation
of this big, huge mountain
in the middle of the--
of the crater.
But as you can see this image,
we haven't lost
sight of Mount Sharp.
It's always sort of been
dead in our sights.
And we are actually
more than half way there
from when we left
the Yellowknife Bay area.
And in fact we see images
like this almost daily
with Curiosity
and it reminds us exactly
why we came here
and why this is the goal.
Because you can see
the layers here
that I described earlier
as sort of chapters in a book.
And you can see here
how they transition
from sort of darker
and grayer layers
near the bottom
to lighter sediments
at the top.
And knowing what we already
know about Gale Crater
from our exploration
of these lake and sediments
washed down in the fan,
we are very eager to get here
and understand more
about the evolution
of the Martian climate
as these sediments
were deposited.
( applause )
( outro music )